[Music]
these emperor penguins are about to
undertake one of the greatest Feats of
Endurance on the
[Music]
planet
a single
egg it's taken almost all this Mother's
energy to
create time to entrust it to her
mate while she leaves to feed at
sea
[Music]
now it's up to
that he must carry the egg through the
world's worst
winter risk his own life to keep the
chick growing inside
alive
just one of the many remarkable stories
of how life triumphs at the ends of the
[Music]
Earth
when winter hits the polar regions the
temperature can drop as low as-
120°
F almost nothing
grows winds build into some of the
strongest on
Earth we got Land and Sea locked in
ice and weeks of Perpetual
Darkness only a few remarkable animals
have what it takes to survive
here and every day is a struggle against
the elements and each
other now the poles are changing faster
than anywhere else on the
planet and getting through the coldest
days that's just the beginning of the
battle
late fall polar bears are
grounded once the sea has frozen over
they can head out and begin
hunting but since the
1970s that's taking
longer hunger claws for an extra 3
weeks and this young male must face
other
challenges
an older
rival
the largest of all land
Predators male polar bears lead a life
of V
bance but today punches are being
pulled sparring partners test strength
and
[Music]
skill preparing for tougher
times when the battle for food and mates
will be
real but
first
patience wait for
[Music]
winter
the magic
number
28.8
F seawater begins to
[Music]
freeze an ice kingdom is
born almost Limitless hunting
grounds the harshest season is when
polar bears
Thrive the Arctic plunges into 24 hours
of
night
around the poles the planet's magnetic
field puts on an unearthly
display in the north the Aurora
[Music]
Borealis and in in the South the Aurora
Australis winter here looks
Heavenly but for these emperor penguins
it's hell on
Earth all of them are m
and if the eggs they're carrying are to
survive all of them must stand
strong
each one takes their turn in the full
force of the
wind all the time balancing their eggs
on their
toes just beyond the Ice's deadly
reach
[Music]
75 days of
sacrifice finally over
[Applause]
it was worth
it just 6
oz he's got a lot of growing to
do soon the ice on which they stand will
oh be
[Music]
gone this is Canada's last land before
the Arctic pack
ice
somehow an eight strong pack of Arctic
wolves survives
here during the brutal winter finding
food is a daily
struggle but after almost three months
of darkness array of
[Music]
Hope
otic hairs are one of the few other
creatures that survive
here gathering in huge groups offers
protection and now the sun has
returned the element of surprise is gone
a lot of effort for no
return there are bigger opportunities
here but they come with greater
risks Musk Oxen
one of the arctic's true
survivors in their search for food the
Arctic Wolf Pack can cover 50 miles in a
day
these Musk Oxen have spent all winter in
this Frozen
Wasteland they're built to
survive
but just one adult would feed the entire
pack to witness wolves hunt musen in
winter is so rare it's never been
captured on
camera until
now
this herd has a
youngster but it's protected behind a
united
front armed with slashing horns adults
weigh up to
700b
[Music]
the Wolves search for weakness in their
defense
try to get them on the
Run
the mother won't leave her Cal but her
instincts work against
her
I
in such a brutal landscape one animal's
survival often depends on another's
fate
in the South the sun's power is
[Applause]
increasing it's been 12 weeks since he
hatched
in fewer than 4 months all this will
have
melted by then chicks must be ready to
swim his life depends on how quickly he
[Music]
grows in just
150 days his body weight must increase
[Music]
times strengthening Sun promises easier
times but down
here promises are easily
broken antarcticus freezing winds have
become more
ferocious
a hole in the planet's ozone lir is
disrupting the atmosphere altering the
weather even though dad hasn't returned
from fishing the chick now needs so much
food mom must go
too
his instincts are to
follow but it's a
mistake he's walking away from
[Music]
safety
I
unless he makes it back to the Colony he
will
die in
Antarctica a storm has hit the emperor
penguin colony
[Music]
it's taken a heavy
toll but most have survived
keeping each other
[Music]
alive separated chicks must now find
their
[Music]
parents
somewhere amongst
177,000
penguins
is his
[Music]
father his call is
unique reunited and
safe these chicks have learned an
important life
lesson The Colony only survives by
standing
together spring races across the
[Music]
Arctic the change brings new
challenges a young
female she depends on seals for
food
the only prey with enough calories to
sustain
her as the ice
melts Escape routs are now
everywhere her chances
[Music]
plummet
Bears have an acute sense of smell
they can detect seals from nearly 2
miles this one's
[Music]
closer
[Applause]
[Music]
a
news of her kill carries on the
wind a huge
male he needs food too and he doesn't
care how he get
[Music]
it just
bones
she's taken her
fill now she must
leave a hungry male polar bear can turn
[Applause]
cannibal summer in the poles has always
been a time of
transformation but now the Arctic is
changing faster than at any rate in
recorded
history the climate is warming
[Music]
polar bears face immediate survival
choices head deeper into the
ice or Swim for
land
either way four lean months lie
[Music]
ahead climate change at the poles will
bring challenges for
many but for some it's
opportunity
over 50 years the average temperature
here has risen by around 5°
F Gen 2 penguins like it warmer than
their ice loving Emperor
[Music]
cousins it exposes the bare rock they
need for
nesting the waters here are so rich
successfully raising two chicks is far
more
[Music]
likely who feed first is decided by a
Chase
[Music]
chicks are at all
stages the oldest are ready for the
sea
but their first taste of the ocean may
also be their
last a changing climate around
Antarctica is helping Gen 2 penguin
populations but even in summer
conditions can deteriorate
rapidly storms blow Brash ice into
Shore
the route back to the Colony is
blocked fledglings must negotiate a maze
of floating
ice it's all too easy to get left
behind and that's not the only
[Music]
danger pushing through Brash ice is hard
work
but this is not a safe place to
[Music]
rest
Panic drives them
on a leopard
seal
a 12T long penguin
Predator attention turns to the
[Music]
straggler
the more he
struggles
the easier he is to
find
leopard seals like to toy with their
victims
[Music]
with so much prey
about there's no
[Applause]
rush
a last Act of defiance
The One That Got
Away still there's plenty of other
Penguins to play
[Music]
with
summer
intensifies ice continues to
retreat
polar bears are
stranded their toughest
[Music]
time surviving on fat built up last
winter reserves are running
low
there's almost nothing to
eat
almost at this time of year beluga
whales arrive in Canada's shallows
a sanctuary for
newborns these Waters can be 18° warmer
than the Open
Sea this could be his
lifeline they're tantalizingly
close one of the few whales with
flexible necks the belugas easily see
him
coming
with each dive he wastes precious
energy and his chances of surviving
summer get
[Music]
Slimmer on the doors of Hudson Bay a
hungry polar bear is desperately trying
to hunt beluga
whales catching them in open water has
proved almost
impossible but he can't let this
opportunity slip
away a change in
tactic from the The Rock prey is easier
to
spot if only they would come in
range
built for the
cold suffering in the
Sun
finally a cal
not fat like an adult but perhaps just
enough to keep starvation at
[Music]
Bay hunting beluga whales might make the
difference between life and death for
these
bears but if the ice free season gets
longer even this may not be
enough
polar animals have evolved to survive
the coldest harshest conditions on Earth
but now the polar regions are warming
more rapidly than anywhere else this
means new opportunities for some but for
the most cold adapted there are
seriously challenging days ahead
the question is can they find new ways
to adapt to a fast changing
[Music]
world the emperor penguin parents are on
the home stret
[Music]
together they've traveled thousands of
miles keeping their chicks fed
he hatched out at under a
pound now he's over 20 almost as big as
his
parents
soon they'll stop returning with food
chicks will be catching their
[Music]
own
this family have done everything they
can in the hope that their chick will
one day
return and the incredible story of Life
at the polls will
continue
[Music]